uh
if you're tuning in we're missing one of
the three amigos it's down to two
it's a two-man uh wolf pack here malik
uh
malc was fired because he lied about
playing basketball west l.a
that's why he's not here i found out i
talked to the coach yeah and they said
we've never had a number six named malik
b
no uh malek's not here because
yeah max doing his own thing malik
decided
you know he wants to focus on his own
[ __ ] you know his own podcast he does
his
uh show with our boy justin who he does
called cutting weight
so he's gonna do that i think he'll do
more episodes with that he's gonna start
doing some of his own weekends so
listen you guys know this being on the
show is a lot of demand especially if
i'm not on the road it's it's three days
a week man that's a lot to
besides rogan i don't know anybody else
who's doing more than you know once or
twice a week
so what is wrong with you rowan does
five now
he does five five three hour longs as
theo said three hours yeah still
got done doing rogan for the first time
he was i've never talked that long
somebody in my life dog
he goes i haven't talked to my therapist
that long i'm trying and when you think
about it
i literally got straight i'm like who
about i've never talked to my dad for
three hours [ __ ] hours never
even wrong oh when i was a kid we're on
a road trip we didn't talk the whole
time no like rogan you got talked the
whole time
dog he did a five-hour podcast with bert
what five hours i mean they were
drinking what i did when i did my
episode with my dad i did two
three long two's long three two weeks
but it's different because we have a lot
to catch up on yeah but just
just the homie the homie i don't want to
talk for my homie
i don't talk to anybody for three hours
i don't wanna do anything for three
hours three years i don't have
sex for three hours i don't watch
fighting for three hours
i don't have nothing the only thing i
want the only thing in this world i
wanna do for three hours or more is
hanging out with my kids hey don't
the fight fights last that long yeah but
at least we're not talking
yeah unless you invite mark and his wife
come on come on mark you know what's
under you know what it
our boy mark harley over and his uh
beautiful german wife
and uh we had him over for the fight to
work some thai food
yeah the chatty
it's called badass thai oh it's in the
valley really that's my goat
is that the only only location no uh i
think i hope it's by me it's not like a
chain
it's not damn that that was probably the
best thai food i think it's
nice right yeah because i like it real
spicy and they go up to put their level
five and i can get five
but that spices get thai spicy or like
they're regular no thai spices
oh that's the real [ __ ] would be that i
like my knives was like it was like the
perfect amount of spice like you did
three years of three but it was like
perfect
permanently permanently closed for what
let's take a look don't they know the
world is opening
i think it's called badass tai i typed
in uh
badass ty but then this popped up thai
badass is it not time is it what is it
there's another one did you say where
it's at
hold on look at my history my postmates
yeah looking history dog i'm pretty sure
what did you guys order from like what's
your thai order is it
he does like the pad thai pack is
pineapple fried rice yeah how do you
know that because you said it once oh
well yeah and then i guess then i get
that guy hollywood
what's tom kai dum guy tom kai is a soup
that's hollywood for
florida is it yeah
we also had a badass thai place in uh
austin too
i've i've oh ty is probably my favorite
i think he'll swing to i forget what
that one is there's a place called
noodle monster on
i think lancashire that's pad thai is
really good though really yeah but it's
called
monster but does it keep up does it keep
up with bad ass tired or whatever oh no
it's called
fire ass touch oh that's a dope name
this guy or logo is legit i ordered from
it all the [ __ ] time i can't remember
the name
badass die fire yeah something asked
high
dude the yelp rating is terrible
are you sure the right one yeah what is
it
i've never seen this ever we're not
doing this thai place justice right now
dude i'm pretty sure there's another
invite though this yeah no that's urban
no that's what dude that's what i
ordered from irvine
no not irvine it's called fire ass tie
it's off it's 2022
ventura boulevard there's
yeah that's it right there i'd like to
put a disclaimer brendan has great taste
in food
yes he has great taste in food you're
not just like eat whatever first of all
they get if they got a bag no look they
have four out of four
stars out of five 192 yeah okay so yeah
irvine is uh slacking but this this the
one we had
that you brought to the crib man that
was the time oh did your girl
you took some home and your girl ate it
yeah we ate some it's good
i missed most the main card fights
because they were talking
you know how when when i watched fights
i went pretty oh yeah yeah you were
pretty silent
because mark mark's a chatty dude yeah
which i don't mind because he knows the
fight game
and also like mark when even though
mark's chatty he's also really
intelligent so you're super interested
in what he's like
saying usually when he talks it means
something yeah it means it's always
meaningful even though but that is i was
talking because there's
uh i think his name jeff herzog he's my
first ref
and it was in denver when i fought chase
gormley and i was coming off the loss on
the
ultimate fighter so it was my first real
ufc fight yeah and he was in the back
you know the ref comes in to tell your
instructions
so then so then he was one of the refs
for one of the fights
and there's two 145 pound guys and she
goes oh my god because i was telling
mark the story of that and he's like
we'll have the fight going like i
knocked him out like
53 seconds he's like oh damn she's like
oh my god you knocked that guy in 53
seconds
like what she's like that guy and i was
like he's 145 pounds
yeah she's like you didn't fight him
like you guys got to get going
she's just like understanding and it's
so wild because
mark watches fights all the time pride
by himself in the dark though like i
wonder
it has to be i thought she would have
understood yeah but
march you're not invited back did i tell
you i saw
at least i i think i think it was him i
actually i
100 percent think it was 100 yeah who is
it jean-claude van damme
where uh how could you not get on the
show what if we don't always say that
alex's gone but jean-claude van damme's
hair
i don't want my ass kicked not seen
bloodsport yeah
right he's firing that man uh he lives
in marina
he knows miranda he lives by china he
was i knew was him does
what does his hair look like right now
can we see this i don't know because i
want it i want to make sure it was him
because i i think it was but uh he
he was drawing some badass bentley
really i mean he's still
i'm sure he's crushing it in life still
he has to be
he had a documentary i think he was on
show time uh jay
junck jcvd and it was uh
this a pretty dope dope uh documentary
he's talking about his coke problems
[ __ ] like that
is this what he looks like right now
should be 12 hours ago
did his hair look good or no yeah but
definitely a toupee dog
have you ever seen one take the head off
you ever seen when he was at there's a
reason why he's wearing a hat
um although i wear hats all the time
that's an old picture april 18.
yeah that's an old picture he's covering
it anyways yeah i i
100 think it was him you didn't say
nothing to him no what do you want to
say to him
i don't know i don't know i mean like
you know what like it's one of those
things with him like i was just like
i'll let that man be
because i'm pretty sure he probably gets
stopped a lot that's probably the way to
go you know what i mean there's certain
people who are
talking about old school [ __ ] blood
sport reference yeah he's like yeah what
am i what am i gonna say to him like
but i [ __ ] loved you in bloodsport
i've never seen more
yeah i've seen bloodsport more than any
movie i've ever seen
in this entire world maybe i've never
watched it quote that [ __ ] you oh yeah
we've watched on the road
oh yeah yeah every character me and my
brother watch that movie
every day after school probably three
years straight nonstop we know
everybody so then we grew up in venice
in the summers we're at gold's gym
and uh chung lee was at gold's gym and
my brother's like holy [ __ ] you know
uh
he's been in bruce lee films too yeah he
i think he still looks great
so we saw my goals he's short but he's
[ __ ] swole
and we were kids we're probably nine i
was probably nine my brother's like 11
and we see my brother's like oh [ __ ]
there's chung lee i'm like oh [ __ ] we're
freaking out who's our movie
and my brother goes up to me i just
don't think he speaks english very well
but we didn't know that we're kids my
brother goes oh what's up chung lee
but and he goes and like brushes off
because he's in the middle of his
workout yeah
and my brother was so offended he goes
man i'm glad jean-claude van damme
kicked your ass
i was like what's wrong with you dog
what the [ __ ] that's like the worst
thing
jay was a little baby kid i'm like [ __ ]
with chun li man
meanwhile he could have [ __ ] all up he
could've my dad was there yeah i think
he yeah he still looks great
he's what bruce lee film was he in enter
the dragon inner dragon was that one
yeah
he's old school man he is dude oh they
got a badass mural of him
he was jacked too and he's chinese right
chin young
what's his young yeah what's his real
name
bolo young oh it's polo
how do you say it young chinese american
forty
so wait chinese american he's a 74 years
old bodybuilder born in
straight up china gongzo god he was
great why are they
dual nationally chinese-american you
probably got citizenship maybe oh
that's is that what that means his
english wasn't good but we didn't know
that as kids and it really pissed jay
off
oh yeah
they've been friends for eight days any
time
anywhere oh is that what he says no time
anywhere
because i love you love you brother when
they grab hands i'm like you guys have
known each other for eight days wait
doesn't he get with the blonde chick at
the end
no he gets with her during the movie
remember he's in his undies doing the
split after he
nutted all of it she's like reporter and
they hook up in the hotel
and then she wakes up and she's like oh
well she's all out of here
what and then he's just [ __ ] in the
room and just switched yeah he's whitey
tighties which is why i still wear
whitey ties this day
and he's doing the splits and she's like
what the [ __ ] do you think she's still
hot
oh i don't know she probably is
father thomas i'm a son of a [ __ ] no
people not there's some people
dude i still i still wish you would have
uh asked john claude to be our third
host
you imagine i couldn't i couldn't go i
don't know there's certain people that
i'm like
i'll leave them alone that's either
gonna be dope or it's gonna be a
nightmare he just keeps talking about
old school stories about being on set up
[ __ ] blood sport or junk
or cyborg or some [ __ ] look oh she looks
great
that was around the movie right yeah
that's what yeah that's right that's
after that
yeah she looks great yeah she's still
yeah she looks great yeah
foxy yeah she was such a dying me in
that movie
mm-hmm that og curly hair you know that
big dude picks her up
he's like trying to [ __ ] her and then
and then john
in that bar it didn't make sense though
because it was like an asian dude but he
had a turban on
it's very strange turbidon and then
remember john clyde gets the quarter out
and then he makes it disappear
and then he puts in his hand oh yeah
yeah he's like if i take it you leave
her alone he's like deal
very english saw tear when he put his
hand on jungle
and i guess they were betting to [ __ ]
the girl
hey that's like that's what they did
back in the 80s man that's the 80s i i
listen
that is frowned upon don't do it now no
christian don't do anything like that
now frowned upon
christian any update on the short kings
let's take a little break
from chatting with my boy chappelle
lacy because listen the hits keep on
coming from one box event to the next
they grow in excitement you guys can't
wait for them and this weekend is no
different man with two of the sport's
most respected fighters
stepping into the ring saturday night
there's no better place to get in
all the action with draftkings
sportsbook america's top raid sportsbook
app for this weekend's fight draftkings
is offering all
new users a shot at turning one dollar
into 55
that's right one equals 55 to celebrate
this weekend's huge event
we're talking canelo we freaking billy
joe saunders we got it all man
to celebrate all this draftking sports
week is offering new use
the opportunity to get 55 to one odds on
either main event fighter
to win this weekend's fights that's bet
one dollar if the fiery choice wins you
cash 55 dollars
plus with basketball hockey playoffs
right around the corner draftking
sportsbook has even more ways to make it
rain
draftking sportsbook is safe secure and
reliable
meaning you can deposit get your funds
whenever you want man
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now use code fighter
when you sign up for limit time only all
new users can bet one dollar to win 55
on this weekend's main event that's
right draftking sportsbook is going all
out
for the new users by offering you guys a
chance to win 55
when you place a one dollar bet on this
weekend's big fight
canelo billy joe saunders get you some
only after african sportsbook must be 21
or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only new
customers only
restrictions applies to draftkings.com
sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 100 gambler or an
indiana 1 809 with it
this episode fighter and the kids
is brought to you by bluenile.com listen
there's a bunch of stuff popping off we
got mother's day i got my girl's
birthday coming up may 5th cinco de mayo
there's a lot going on man and there's
only one place one stop shop
for all jewelry we talking about blue
now they're in the business of wedding
jewelry
engagement rings bands everyday fine
julie
diamond jewelry cocktail rings gemstone
necklaces we got it all man
whether you're customizing an engagement
ring or designing diamond stud earrings
at bluenow.com you got this you're in
control of whatever you want to do man
all right whether you're ready to pop
the question or mark a special occasion
like mother's day whatever it is
birthday
blue now got you covered build the
engagement ring of her dreams man we
gotcha
celebrate life's special moments with
blue nile bluenyle.com is the original
online jeweler since 1999
they've helped millions of couples
create their perfect engagement ring
they've also helped millions of dudes
give their girls or
gals or other dudes the perfect gift
right so make the moment sparkle with
jewelry from bluenow.com
and the fire and the kids listeners get
50 off
all right this is a podcast exclusive
just for you guys use the code fighter
that's code fighter you get 50 off when
you spend 500 all right
plus every order is insured ships free
and arrives discreet little package so
it doesn't give away the secret
shop stress free find your forever piece
go to bluenile.com
today frowned upon christian any update
on the
short kings uh yeah so i did some
looking into the app it's not even a
real thing anymore
okay the app like it's like what am i
gonna do for you
uh i haven't seen you guys you just
gotta stay on
bumble and just hope tinder's been
pretty good to me lately so i mean
put your height on tinder no you don't
you don't have to put your height
i'm not gonna why would i why would i
advertise that's like why not
cause you might you might be like in a
specialty i didn't make my bio
summer you you said what short king
summer
that's what you wrote yeah that's dope i
like how you wearing a cream a scream
t-shirt like it's [ __ ] the early
2000's right it's a great movie
you're born in 98. yes you seen the
movie shout out to nef campbell i grew
up on
all the like all of the movies they're
like early 2000s late 90s
like american pie yep one two and three
five yeah
all three great um yeah i like grew up
on that um
all like all the adam sandler movies
like mr deeds
big daddy big daddy daddy uh happy
gilmore
billy madison nikki i met the next one
the twin from uh sprouse yeah i met one
of them
both of them are in i don't know which
one yeah they're both
yeah that's why they used to have a lot
of twins one day olsen twins
yeah yeah because they can only be on
for so long because it's like three or
four hours and then
the third olson is killing it they're
all killing it they're
all waiting all three of them the other
two are like fashion moguls they're
worth like billions at all or some [ __ ]
they're worth billions
maybe not billions i throw that term
around a lot but they're worth a lot of
them
they're worth
they were worth enough to not do the
reboot of uh
they don't have time for that what the
hell is that show called fuller house
i heard i heard one of the sprouse
brothers espress brothers also have been
doing this [ __ ] for a really long time
because they were in friends
like they played the kid in france yeah
it was yeah
but one of them like just uh one of
them's on like a cw show now
uh uh riverdale yeah they're just
hustling sorry
i shouted in like a restaurant or
something i heard
no it's not like acting anymore that
must be is that where you saw him that
must be a bummer like
no he's like he's from he was working at
work are you the kid from big daddy's
school in new york
and like do and like working in a
restaurant on the side they came in no
avocado
quick question do you wipe your own ass
dude are you frankenstein from big daddy
nobody
it was the other one it wasn't the one
that's in riverdale no yes yes so i was
saying yeah
that's not the one i met the one i met
is like dylan the waiter dylan yes yeah
he's not a waiter he was i'm he was he
was eating the same food i was
maybe he was on break no i'm telling him
i'm just trying to enjoy my break man
come on man yeah
yes really finally killing it huh
they're kind of yeah that's the one i
met
uncle oh well that's one i wouldn't i
wouldn't be like oh are you a kid from
big daddy if i saw him i'd like oh are
you macaulay culkin
weird brother islam i went up to when i
was like hey job
big fan been watching since i was oh
really and what'd he say he's like we're
the same age right
yeah like you're older than me he was
just like
all right let's take a look he's like
yeah you're like no i don't want to pick
all right
i don't want to say anything to
jean-claude van damme no i'd say
something to him wait
john clyde's a legend this is a kid hey
did you uh but you ran into the weekend
too
yeah i did run into the weekend at uh
crossroads he's got a he got that
michael jackson voice
does he walk by did you say what's up to
him uh
i looked at him he goes what's up oh he
has that sock yeah yeah
and i think i think they do that like
certain singers do that because they
don't
save their voice he had to save their
voice so he was like what's up
me and my girl like what the [ __ ] is
real soft yeah because i thought he
would have like a
deeper voice really like he's hit those
high notes i know like some people have
deep voice but you can hit that falsetto
that crossroads that's that vegan my boy
travis barker's restaurant yeah
even if you don't like vegan i'm all
about that yeah
i mean i've been vegan a lot yeah good
dog i'm probably like i'd say i'm 90
vegan hey but so uh the weekend sets up
to you when he's passing by
yeah because it's only because i was
looking at it those guys are like guys
like the weekend or drake though
they're so famous remember when you saw
me just got done with the super bowl
performance
they're so famous and they know when
they walk in somewhere
everybody knows who they are those are
my girls so he knows when you're looking
like yeah
what's up yeah he's like what's up
oh wow i was like
is he party so hard into so many drugs
people have to stop [ __ ] with him
really yeah like he goes so hard in the
paint with drugs and partying where
drake and everyone's like dog we out man
it's so weird because
he seems like a very reserved like chill
dude i don't even think he's
like demi lovato and she's like dog you
gotta stop me
yeah she's like you gotta stop doing
cocaine oh yeah he was with selena gomez
like [ __ ] that noise just [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
i i'd say i'm taller than him but he
wasn't that short you're like what five
eleven five eleven you think he was like
five eight
yeah i'd say he's probably like five
eight i feel like that's fairly short
yeah i'm with kevin yeah
you i never think he's like short short
but he's definitely a short king in my
eyes
so what makes a short king then i'd say
five eight and below
eight and under five eight and under and
you're five eight i wish
this man out here five you can't be
short the short king be
five eight people like like people want
you to be short yeah
i don't want to be short though but yeah
it's the card you're a dealt dog
robbie's seeing everybody at the
crossroads i mean that's the spot it is
who did i see
i i that's cool
yeah just 2004. oh he's still killing it
no he's great
he's great don't you dare i'm no i love
you
no he's great i love him b i wouldn't
stop i'm telling you i went i wouldn't
i'd prefer if i saw fergie i like fergie
more than him
you don't like fergie freaky's banging
he's the reason why fergie was put on
how dare you
he was what was what was she where was
she at before that bee she was
like a girl band right i don't think so
just [ __ ] well not a good girl
like she was struggling she was
struggling
no will i am
and i think william does like a bunch of
producing still
i'm just saying i wouldn't what did her
what does it say
original member of the children's series
incorporated in the girl group
wow he told you a wild orchard what is
that
you never heard of wow orchid you've
never heard of wild wild
it sounds like you haven't heard of a
mind i've never heard of it
the point is
she's still banging though i mean yeah
of course yeah fergie's great you ever
see that performance where she's like
doing
uh front hand springs and singing yes
like i think it was on uh it was
wonderful good morning american lives
are like good morning yeah like wait
where are they making fun of her no bruh
she's like
like she's singing live singing like as
she spins and she's going
to watch you practice it's one of my
favorite videos
she's in shape watch her get it
get it fergie
here she goes
she knew this [ __ ] was live
now didn't j lo tried singing the same
song and she got [ __ ] for it remember
that
uh i think she's singing was she i think
she was singing welcome to the jungle
right yeah
she's sitting well in the jungle bruh
she was going off and on front hand
springs though
now did fergie make it on her own or
yeah [ __ ] bruh
because afterwards oh that's right
glamorous that's burglary
to knock my boy will i am no i'm all i'm
saying is i wouldn't right he
produces for a lot of people no no you
got to realize i'm not in the music
industry so i don't give a [ __ ] bro i've
been like oh there's
you will and keep going we cannot be
like oh damn there's a weekend
i when i was at a super bowl party i
bumped into uh tom cruise
oh you dude and he was i was like i
thought he'd be shorter but he i looked
down and his
[ __ ] platforms were like this i was
like oh damn damn he had platforms
some dudes do that like prince i would
never okay
i'm just checking i'm gonna have to
check it you don't you could wear like
doc martens no i wear i wear like tins
like
i'd wear like tim's if anything get like
an extra inch or two
no two inches is a big deal yeah i know
but like i wouldn't want to look i
wouldn't wear
platforms you ever wearing shoes too
small because they're fire like these
travis scots they got a size 12 i wear
13 so my big toe is
killing it right now but there's such
fire shoes
that's what you got to do that's why i'm
binding my feet travis scott
they sent me the wrong size i took the
soles out and [ __ ]
can you get like a shoe stretcher or
like stuff them with a bunch of socks so
they stretch
these shoe stretchers help i think i
don't know if they helped that much
i've never used you're great it's
cobbler or something like that oh that's
right
yeah i did do that oh but though i i
know i did with uh these uh
[ __ ] uh louis vuitton uh boots i got
um
what what i heard what you can do is hum
what i heard you can do is take a
plastic bag fill it with water
put it in the shoe then put in the
freezer because you know water expands
it will expand the [ __ ] out of the shoe
i don't think i'm at that point right
now it's my big toe
yeah i know these are going to ask neil
degrasse tyson next you know what the
[ __ ] do i do i need to do something
yeah wait wait you you rock doc martin
boots
no not me he could though or no uh louis
vuitton boots
uh not louis vuitton what the [ __ ] is
the name
no it's [ __ ] uh not louis vuitton you
just seem so sneaker
uh yeah but like when i was doing like
the mcgregor stuff for showtime
they didn't want sneakers so i started
wearing boots a lot i got a lot of dope
books are they the same ones that
brought chelsea
no brian got gucci never wears any
self-conscious about them yeah
no they're not louis vuitton god what
are they
i forget the [ __ ] name of them oh
okay why
why why do you think of that can you
just give some appreciation of will i am
that'd be great no yeah i love will i am
this one that's all i needed
i mean those are gucci i love those you
would wear those bee
i don't that's me oh that's your that's
you that's me and that's my
foot it's the ugliest thing i've ever
seen in my life
no you don't dig those no no more
christmas ass shoes those are hard as
[ __ ] dog
what those are yours too that donald
duck is that donald yeah those are good
oh i got that [ __ ] right hell yeah
i don't know god forget the name
yeah no either way though i forget the
name
okay yeah there's no way i can yeah i'll
rock oh yeah both were on ridiculousness
yeah my first appearance was with brian
and i told her
he's great right there he looked young
there huh and i told brian
before he still looks great yeah
especially for his age
i told brian before uh we did the show
i'm like you gotta watch and see what
the concept is just don't wing it man
know what you would sign up for
so we get there i'm like hey dog he's
saying this episode you watch he's like
nah what are we doing i was like [ __ ] no
like you have no ideas like no what's
the show like they sent us all the clips
we gotta watch the clips and then we
we we comment on the clips he's like
i'll figure it out like god damn it dude
did he do good he probably did it you
know it's brian it's brian yeah he did
his thing
he probably killed it dang look at you
there too
yeah i don't know how much i weighed
there look at all skinny and [ __ ] though
we missed you at zoo today man you dude
yep
uh some did some comics send you a
picture of me yeah that's that's me and
mark's uh homie
that's why he goes yeah ma'am start
coming up here working out with you guys
like
she do you just invite yourself to the
workout room yeah because i don't know
you doug
no he's a he's a cool kid you're cool
yeah yeah he's i mean you're in the
lifting group yeah
i know he sent us the picture and it was
like i was like where the [ __ ] is
brendan at cause i didn't think he'd be
at
zu because he said he lives all the way
in uh redondo
oh that's a nightmare yeah and i'm like
you're driving all the way to the
[ __ ] zoo culture
he's like i love this place man i saw
you guys post on social media decide to
drive up here
i was like yeah i'm you know usually
being the guys are here around eight and
he's like you can you come at hey i'm
like oh no i just told him what time
no no he's cool he's no he seemed cool
yeah yeah he's so funny because all he
works is bench
look at me being that gym guy now you
know what's up okay i'm just you did 250
for what eight on ink line doug
250 for eight do you see my 350 350 talk
about your squad no i'm talking
on your incline bro you didn't see my
squads first of all you can compete
like if you wanted to compete in
powerlifting you would [ __ ] kill it
you're strong as [ __ ] and you have great
range of motion
you have good forms oh cheerleaders did
you where did you do this look at justin
someone said hold on wait close that
someone said just to look like a bottle
of pepto pizza because he was
he was talking about fashion we were
talking about fashion right there
look at his shirt and what's he saying
justin knows that start it over jim
it's pretty pretty funny quick so justin
does the cut and weight podcast with
mallet
yeah i really dress up when i'm on
podcast like when i'm in my everyday
life i'm really dressed down
and when i see y'all in studio i'm
really dressed up because again you
never know
who could be around and who who you may
see for real so you gotta really
watch up you and your sweatpants
everybody and the crew in these
sweatpants hopefully i can bring some
type of pizzazz to the crew
i'm hoping to spark it even even on the
flights
yeah man i tried to do it even on the
flights he does not try to do that you
know what's so smooth about justin too
justin before he goes on stage he has
the do-rag on
always guys listen right before he's
about to go on that stage right when
justin elliott takes it off as soon as
he gets off that stage
he put that [ __ ] right back
watch what he says about me the waves
the hair game again even though
you know the first one right now
chapelle i am so glad you cutting the
muffin top
i was i was about to put a pole in
who was downing you on there it was just
like
in the comments she probably need to cut
that
i was in the comments she found it oh
yeah
surely you could before i knew him i was
like who is that i'm in my everyday life
yeah bro he's [ __ ] hilarious but uh
his fashion game's on point
on point uh but yeah go to that school
go ahead and go to that squad
go ahead you did this without me yep
dude what was this
uh that was after we came back from
naples and i went straight to the gym
oh where yeah barefoot too that's 315.
and that's
easy for you yeah for 10.
everyone keeps talking about my butt
saying it's good yeah
someone someone goes la 10 peach spotty
face
great lion
yeah that's no punk no
that's hella mark saying i got this
damn
yeah it's so strong what's weird i don't
know how how i don't know
what you know like are you a big
squatter i was in college we had to
squat
yeah now he's too tall yeah um
like you're definitely more built for
squat um
like for me like i'll do dead lift i'll
do heavy deadlift now
like squat like i'll do those like that
machine they have we put the
the the [ __ ] cable on the pit shark
yeah i love it oh
think about how often does he doesn't
make a squat that often no
i just wanted to do it that day to see
if i could get 10. yeah he has strong
legs
yeah strong legs strong legs yeah he's
like sticking what's up
dog yeah i can't wait till these thighs
come down a little bit though
you haven't figured out your gene game
not yet but i mean you say that link and
you just i send you [ __ ]
but you send it by your gay friend you
know what but i i get so [ __ ]
frustrated
why just because i'm like i'm like this
drives me crazy because
i don't know if i've ordered this and it
comes and then it won't fit and then
like then i don't have the because
follow through that's what i'm saying
all it's too small and that's what it is
but you you may have to
usually stick with your spot i know what
works for me yeah
exactly so like if i've never gone there
it's always
like it's stressful for me now i get it
and like anytime i go to shop somewhere
they just do not have
where i could try on the jeans are like
oh you know
we they do make this size but you got to
go online and i'm like
well but i know my [ __ ] when it comes to
jeans like the flexible [ __ ] especially
for your thighs
your legs are longer than mine i know
but still you just get it shorter like i
wear you know
what 38 because it's going to fit on my
thighs and my ass
that's what i wear my waist is 36. yeah
my asses makes it a [ __ ] but if you
wear 30 you
but you do 38 and then we can always
tailor it we could always take a tailor
i got a dope tailor yeah i gotta go
through all this for some [ __ ] job
jeans are not man i want sweatpants for
the rest of my life
at least you're honest about it you're
talking to guys we're in a size 12 right
now and my feet are gone
exactly i do it for the game i'm not i'm
not doing that for the game no i know
you know how uncomfortable jeans are
do you know my thighs rub your thighs
don't touch
yeah they do your thighs touch you have
that thigh gap
yeah i've never seen that that i get
what
i mean it's like this really that's you
i ain't got a thigh gap my [ __ ]
thighs are like yeah yeah yeah
they're hanging the [ __ ] out yeah quit
staring at him like that though what's
up daddy
no you need to uh you need to take my
advice with those jeans
and just look into it man i just please
take this shot i didn't show my homie
he does help me out a lot he's helped me
find like a lot of jeans
he's really good with fashion my boy
oh that's the fashion guy yeah that's my
homie yeah
yeah he can't work out with us huh
mm-hmm he's so interesting he's gay gay
he's like gay you know some guys are
like
man whatever man no he gay gay so we
were like nah man
and then i do it sometimes dawg yeah you
know man this is a weekend today
i might do it he gay gay gay guy and he
had an open relationship
and i was like how's that working he's
just open about it he's like i'll be on
the road man and you know i get on the
app and it's game um
we left and i text the group i went damn
chevelle's friend be [ __ ]
up the whole way oh not like as
aggressive as you're
guys want sex all the time and another
dude
you'd be like yo meet me at this he's
making him seem more aggressive than
what it is
wait wait wait you did what what no no i
was gonna say i feel like gay
the gay community is probably the most
horny batch of people on the planet
listen mine most of my sets how much
easier my life would be if i was gay
uh oh yeah that is part of yourself yeah
but i mean he's it's not his that's why
he's asking so many questions i was like
way off uh you know when he told me like
it literally validated everything i tell
i mean if he's if it's more like if you
see something he likes whatever
i know and then the guy's like yeah sure
whatever yeah yeah it's just guys
dude guys guys i was like man you're
killing it
yeah i know yeah you dapped him up like
no way
hold on get back at me
just bust a nut i promise you is
let's get off your gay friend what'd you
do this weekend what talked to you this
weekend
about jen's lease is coming up in june
right when we moved to the new studio
i mean what was there not in june but i
mean it's closer to the end of the year
so
oh for marina yeah because we've got a
new studio i'm gonna be super far from
it it's gonna be a nightmare for you
driving that especially yeah
you know kovid's base you know he's
gonna come back so yeah
yeah yeah that'd be a nightmare for you
to drive i think there was a stat that
we just had uh
first year without uh first day
first year yeah and then florida
announced today all
everything's off all like requirements
for covet and mass
capacity everything's off really yep
there's no coveted mandates in florida
anymore
shout out to santas does that include
you know how the last time we were there
uh certain places would have a role for
that particular like coffee shop like oh
yeah it's up to the business but now i
think it's
the way it works is up to that business
so like starbucks has like a map
like a mandate worldwide but they can't
enforce it
oh okay so i don't think they can oh
yeah i wonder
huh i'll tell you who's getting [ __ ]
annihilated by covert right now as
india yeah but they have 1.4
billion people 1.4 billion yeah they're
all without strand
the strand that's [ __ ] all them up
we've already had it here oh we did
yeah it sucks because yeah i mean
they're just yeah all on top but they
said like
all like so many countries have sent
like relief to them but there's 1.4
billion people so it's like
a pebble in the great it's like a grain
of sand in
the scheme of things like we can't send
enough [ __ ] it's a shame
[ __ ] that's sad and then they're putting
restrictions on india flights
so they can't come here makes sense yeah
we're getting over it we can
yeah i guess we're supposed to be like
fully open june
hollow i know this guy's smiling
he's hitting the body summer coming
though yeah
is like fergie yeah i got to see you she
was like
she was too crunk for that live
performance
she's like come on it's all early in the
morning this good morning america like
yeah she's like say less
you gotta give it to her though she
commits like that and then the
performance at the basketball game
she did like a jazz rendition of the
national anthem oh yeah yeah
oh she got lit up for that yeah but she
committed she committed and then
i think they tried to hate on draymond
for laughing
he'd be tough not to laugh but they all
were laughing they got all their faces
and everybody was laughing they tried
not to they were trying to guess
draymond got the most heat
from it you always get [ __ ] there was an
actor that came at him
for laughing during the national yeah
who's that actor
[ __ ] i don't know do you know what
they're on uh
one of them like redwood movies or what
is that
hallmark um
no what'd you do this weekend christian
what'd you say you do when you're not in
studio
um do you do don't you knew
i was aggressive i'm sorry yeah good
morning
um when i'm not in the studio like i'll
wake up go to the gym come here and then
when i go home i'll
work on some fighter in the kids
software a little uh probably
hang out with my roommates play xbox and
that's about it this weekend
i uh didn't do anything special i just
watched the fights really how's that
get those b-boy pants on i know you're
like the [ __ ] white guy in a b-boy
[ __ ] yeah i said where do you get them
pants dog he's like i just found him in
the closet yeah
and he was like yeah these are these are
the ones they're making you appreciate
this
peter text me goes hey man you're new
your new uh guys are great with social
media
he goes you know they asked me to cut 65
clips last month yeah and i charge per
clip i'm like what the [ __ ]
i didn't know that in my defense so i
thought he was just on pay like with
like everyone else i didn't know it was
per clip so that's how we figured it out
i got the email what the what you guys
figured out so yeah let's go all day
would you do cat you chill with stevie
uh no
uh stevie was actually in boston
visiting some friends my mom came into
town
and i think my mom secretly loves stevie
oh that's good everyone loves steve
that's good
mama where she was asking where is that
yeah she was asking where he's at
because the day that
he left my mom got there and they were
hanging out for a little bit he was
eating a bunch of vietnamese food just
like
being good with your mom yeah because my
mom came over
made vietnamese food and he was gonna
leave that night but he was eating it
and so she was just like oh i like this
white guy wait is that the first time
they met
no they met one other time before but it
was kind of like the first time they met
so it was very stiff
like hi hello this time it's kind of
emotional
yeah yeah i think my mom like actually
really likes him
but she doesn't want to who doesn't i
don't know anyway it doesn't like yeah
he's pretty
he's he's yeah he's so chill yeah he's
like uh
what that was that damn thing he likes
an alpaca oh packing he's like
yeah yeah that's his energy it really
is now that i really think about it i
don't know if we said that last time we
talked about him in his
alpaca well that's why he's definitely a
fair animal yeah
absolutely spirit animal besides that
spirit animal spirit like you're who you
connect with an animal world
i think well i say like jared leto's my
spirit animal what
yeah all people like he's into fashion
he's real skinny like i wish he was my
spirit oh jared leto or justin trudeau
for you because i know those are like
kind of your top two
yeah say less what does it say uh
spirit animal refers to a spirit which
helps guides or protect the person on a
journey whose care
uh that person shares embodies also a
metaphor often
humorous for someone or something a
person relates to or admires
so that's why jared leto's my spirit oh
hire him i don't think i have
i don't think i have a human he looks
great for 50 though
i don't think the most beautiful 50 year
old my spirit animal you know human no
i don't think of human like what and one
do you think of then what animal uh
for you you know honestly a silverback
silverback gorilla because they're kind
of chill kind of gentle
anger's in there that anger's in nice
it is in there i know i did tell someone
to eat a dick yeah he did and he's
aggressive
yeah hey it's only because of what he
said no it's fair
man one guy called you a sharpie for
god's sake i know yeah
and i was like man that seemed racist
then we came back i was like was that
racist like yeah yeah i know yeah
i think that makes sense yeah i'm trying
to figure it out
like i'm telling you now i think about
it out loud
i took tiger on a hike and you know
because all the flowers in bloom and
[ __ ] so there's
like all these yellow [ __ ] dandelions
everywhere and there's bees
everywhere he hates bees i hate bees so
we're going
it's like all right dude we're either
gonna have to run
this way to get through this or we're
gonna have to turn around because
there's bees everywhere
he goes man let's get the hell out of
here i'm like don't say hell but that's
nice oh yeah he said don't say hell but
let's get the hell out of here that's
hilarious
he likes hikes though oh yeah that's
what we do damn i didn't think about
hikes until i was like in my 20s
oh we got when i'm at home we go all the
time really all the time
where do you normally go all over like
by me like
like yeah there's so many you don't
bring boston on the mother
we have in my [ __ ] back does
[Applause]
yeah he holds it down his new word is
mine mine mine he's like the birds off
of [ __ ]
finding nemo yeah mine mine mine i don't
know this
reference yeah dad life finding me
but finding nemo is like oh gee super
old yeah
finding nemo hell no you know you know
last time american idol was disney night
huh it was disney night american idol oh
the special guest
judge with our like talent was uh john
stamos
oh i love john stamos i love him too
he's only the best
guy yeah he's on like uh some disney i
think he's like a
coach yeah hey didn't you know the show
yeah not gonna watch it but uh yeah if
i'm one of those singers i'm like is
this do you have my advice from john
i know where the [ __ ] is beyonce or
[ __ ] you know a real singer where's
the doubt
yeah that's true uncle jesse right now
yeah
that's like me going on there actually
but
you know he does like he plays with the
beach boys like he'll fill in
no yeah he's actually a musician yeah
he's a musician actually wait i take it
back because that was his whole thing on
full house yeah full house that's right
yeah that's where he came from because
he can actually play yeah that's so low
but again he hasn't made a career in
music and these kids are trying to do
that
but he could play on a grande man like
let me talk something on the voice
yeah it's like did he make an album chin
i just says
he's with the beach boys he's
he's like performed with them live like
going on tour all right this is the
so you know he's a handsome dude he was
in you too by the way season
one yeah he was there he gets it's been
out forever though so
[ __ ] off but he uh
two albums oh oh there you go all right
so yep take your best shot all right
never heard of that
um but he uh brian did a movie with them
yeah they brian
you know brian's charming like they're
both like the same age
of talking to him and he goes dude stop
stop stop hey man unless you got a
private jet i'm all set on friends
oh okay who's the one who said
unless you got a private jet i'm all set
leah bro
you get rap looking all chunky yeah rap
was thick
that's cool he's lost a bunch of weight
how funny is that that
hey what show is that she got a private
jet i'm all sad it's the movie that they
were on oh it's a movie yeah
what did we get in the movie and why
couldn't they put the black dude up
front
yeah loser oh that's right
was it pretty big i don't think so
straight to dvd was it the one that he
got cut out of
or no that was uh think like a man oh he
got kind of
think like a man no he wasn't
he was i think he was i think it was
think like a man
it was yeah kevin hart was in it but
brian goes hey dog i'm in this movie you
want you want to be my guy
and that time i was still fighting he's
like you want to uh go to the premiere
with me i'm like yeah this would be dope
so his wife me and him we're sitting
down the whole
like the movie's like basically like 75
percent down you go
damn dog when are you in it he's like i
don't know i thought i'd be earlier
movie ends and he's just like he looks
at me and sometimes that happens
damn he's like i didn't know i wasn't in
there they don't tell they know he's
like they edited me out
i'm sure they told him he didn't read
the email that's what happened
we got all dressed up where's me
i said hey dog you want a picture by the
poster he's like nah i'm good
that's so messed up no i'm good hey that
actor you just head up that's the actor
that called out uh
draymond green and that little wikipedia
movie thing you had
that's who they actually oh josh josh
dumail that's that that's fergie's
husband
oh that happens full circle they're not
still married right now but i think at
the time
they weren't together
he's not he's not in a dead wood or
something like he's not in a western
uh i don't know he might be you know i'm
getting him confused with another guy
and what what kind of cast is in what
world are we going to believe josh
dumail and megan fox are these homely
people
with this cute [ __ ] kid and why hey
let's hey look what lived
yeah what ten [ __ ] wife is megan [ __ ]
come on man to be fair she had that
moment in her life
yeah with her
yeah like she did the wholesome like
family thing with the older guy
people hate on jennifer's body that's
the [ __ ] that's
jennifer's body quality movie who's
jennifer's body you never seen that
movie
a scary movie you didn't like it no
who's in who's in general amanda
seyfried um
you gotta realize the guy from the oc
yeah that's one the one thing you'll
learn about me i haven't seen a lot
that's a great moment let's do a lot of
reading and journaling it has a cult
following now with younger people
people hate on when it first came out
yeah and then she talked about an
interview and she's like and
people love it just these reviews i just
[ __ ] on so no one gave it a chance
yeah but notice it's always on tv now
yeah oh really let down
at the because like i was like when did
this come out like 2014
like i was young so like i i heard that
megan fox was gonna have a
naked scene i was so excited and then
that's what
it was great that's the girl from mean
girls
yes she's karen yeah i care for me girls
oh you know what i want
you know what else i watched i watched
uh it won best original screenplay oh
the oscars
um it's a movie text me about it he said
i gotta check his revenge or something
like that you know what i'm talking
about
no uh something like the
it's where it's where the girl goes like
tricks
yes i heard it's really good
because you like uh like drumming yeah
dude i'm not going to spoil it for you
guys because it's fairly new the ending
will
[ __ ] trip you out it's so [ __ ]
someone spoiled it for me
i heard what can you give me what was
the gist of it she her her friend in
college her and her friend were in
college her friend was raped and i think
she committed suicide from it
but uh all the guys got off so then she
starts like pretend she's drunk in a bar
just
you know because you know guys are
scumbag so she apparently was drunk in a
bar
and guys would pick her up and take her
home and try to like have sex with her
and then she'd
like the guy'd be going down on her
start to and she's like what are you
doing like what
you're like are you [ __ ] sober and
she's like yep and you're a piece of
[ __ ] and like
but she's just doing it this lead up to
catch these guys who raped her friend
and she gets back at him and it's so
good wow yeah the ending's fantastic
super original is that beau burnham yeah
he's roberto
yeah he's our love interest in it it's
really does he direct it because he
directs film uh not this one
i don't think so he directed that uh the
middle school one right junior or i
think it was called 13
13 or something yeah with that little
girl that movie is crazy
did you watch it yeah yeah yeah i
promise young woman's [ __ ] good
no i was wrong about the num the that
movie
all right jim what do you got give some
current events doug this episode is
brought to you by
unleashed with dingo and danny a new
podcast fueled by monster energy unleash
gets up close and personal with the best
alternative action motorsports
get ready for untold stories career
defining moments and inside secrets from
the world's best athletes and
trailblazers don't miss out on
all the action new episodes drop every
two weeks on mondays listen wherever you
get your podcast or watch on monster
energy's youtube
on leash with danny and the dingo fueled
by monster energy
this episode of firing the kid is
brought to you by my
favorite cbd site man listen cbd is the
wild west and everyone has their
favorite
and thank god for direct hemp because
they're basically the amazon of cbd hemp
oil all right
cbd can be confusing but if you want to
mess with the top
the top brands the ones that you love
and find it all in one simple interface
one page go to hemp direct
that's right man they have all the
brands that i love that you love
in one place so we have to place one
order and you get everything that you
need
all right we got you covered man we're
talking safety quality
innovation charity culture
directhemp.com considers it
all all right we got you covered direct
temp carries like i said the best cbd
products
at the best prices they have something
for everybody man whatever you're
looking for in the cbd area
we got you directhemp.com promo code is
thick you get 10 off the entire freaking
site ordership before 11am central
ship out the same day the same freaking
day
it's dropped off right at your doorstep
all right you can connect direct helps
uh direct hemps customer services 24 7.
they have 100 satisfaction guaranteed
you got nothing i mean nothing to lose
if you're considering trying out uh cbd
this is we can do that because again the
world's top cbd
is profiled on this site they have it
all think of the amazon
cbd we offer it all man with the best
customer service
ships out the same day what do you need
man go to directhem.com promo code
thick and you get 10 off that's right
promo code is thick at directhemp.com
thick with three c's
thick with three c's great point chin
thick with three c's
t-h-i-c-c-cc what's currently happening
happening okay that's what i call this a
segment now wait who is it bo burnham
okay so uh we have talked about billy
eilish in the past and how
she likes to cover up she actually
recently did
a shoot with vogue she's got the sweater
puppies over in the uk
and she did it wearing lingerie and
she's how old now 20. she is 19 turning
20.
she's still only 19 20 yeah well she got
started
like she's been around she's a baddie
yeah she dyed her hair
she's a man now though no yeah is she
yeah she has a straight up dude now oh i
didn't know that uh-huh
but yeah she decided to pose for vogue
as kind of like a
coming out of her like just wearing
whatever she wants she looks so she
looks
like completely ah completely different
mm-hmm she used to have that green hair
now she's just
doing it normal would she wear a lot of
baggy clothes on the regular
she didn't want to be known as like the
sex symbol got it okay you know
that's why it doesn't i'm like this is
really her or no that's her yeah
which like i feel like she was thinking
so far into
her career because she started when she
was 13 and then she started to kind of
like
grow into her body she started covering
up because she wanted them just to focus
on her music and not her body especially
yeah look at that she used to dress all
crazy too just like me
yeah similar story do you take away
watch me get on vogue
yep maybe uh let's you know what you
should forget about voting right
i'm gonna get on vote for forget about
the program right now let's just get
your shirt off
at the zoo listen i could get i believe
and i've listened i've only told myself
this
one day i'll be on the cover of uh gq i
can see that
driven it's usually women but i think
you can as a man you put me in a nice
suit
that's gq good look gq you can for sure
i'm good looking
you look good in a blue suit like a
royal blue suit you know my colors yes
look that could be you man yeah yeah he
was on the cover of votes
yeah so was usher is that oh she made it
who's that no
zayn malik oh i was way
of course naturally come on now dude
denzel
jones clooney yeah i i think i looked
you i think i looked better you wrote
that in your journal
you want to be on the gq you said
why are you making me out to be like i'm
so 14 year old i don't know you're
writing your diary i'm gonna be
on the cover of gq one day
i don't know if he's been in vogue but
he's been on men's health a bunch of
times yeah yeah
he got bodied up cover of essence
rolling stone uptown
hollywood reporter vibe
no you could do that dog gq for sure
mm-hmm
vogue let's let's relax a little relax
blindfold
bro like she's what if he puts on a
dress colors what if he puts on a grey
dress like hairstyles
you can do that for vogue i'm gonna put
a little dress yeah that's what i
thought
you don't want any kurt cobain vibes no
cause i you know i i feel like i could
look good without a dress
i don't need that like i feel like i
could pull attention
you know with that just all the extra
stuff i could i could wear this fugazi
t-shirt on
vogue and still kill it probably oh yeah
nah i like your car
yeah i i need i need to drop this yeah
that was yeah that was a little bit more
if they styled it properly i feel like
if they styled me properly it could it's
like some dope pants and shoes
and some jewelry yeah and they'll
probably find the right pants for me yep
they're like oh we know just your size
some bracelets and [ __ ] chains braces
bracelets oh
okay so there is a video going around
uh where a teacher in florida was
paddling a six-year-old child in front
of their mother so it seems like
they were given permission and florida
is one of those states where
they are allowed to do this brennan shot
podcast comedian beats the [ __ ]
you're watching this kid
[Music]
hitting a six-year-old with a wooden
paddle no
oh we're fighting the mother was okay
with it the mother was there
in the article that's what it was today
yeah we're fighting no
little smack that's what i thought
initially too but that
feed off like she was going to hit a
home run you know when chen was younger
they used to do that
yeah i saw it i was so scared of it they
used to do the paddle
uh like yeah at catholic schools they
they uh slap their hands would get
rulers and whack your uh fingers oh you
whack my finger i'm swinging back
he's wrong back regardless i know yeah i
swung back a teacher grabbed my son
wrong by the album coming up there and
fighting
oh yeah i feel like they used to do that
to me all the time the teachers they
would grab me like yeah that that
yeah you like we used to have a
principal principal buckner do it all
just
grab the elbow hard as [ __ ] like what's
wrong with you dude we had above
principal really
yeah this is the name of dr dr hernandez
he's a doctor but yeah because he was
yeah i guess with this one yeah he was a
dope dude
that's who's when i went up when i was
swinging at the teachers when i told you
about that
he's the one that he's one that came in
and slammed me up against the wall and i
slammed and i tried to shove back
bro he's too thick for it that's
probably why they kept grabbing you by
the elbow if i'm being
completely honest you were trying to
stop you from swinging every teacher you
saw
i just grabbed my elbow and i act like i
can't speak tough
but you're a young kid you're a little
kid man you gotta grab that
grown man though i don't respect your
hand are you
so in that story though the mom was
there and located yeah in the article it
says that the mother was
present while her child was getting
paddled now from what i've
read in the article in florida it is
something that is practiced and
something that is allowed
with the permission of the parent so
they generally will send out permission
slips saying like
hey are we able to practice this to your
child
florida is currently within one of 19 19
states in which
uh school corporal punishment is allowed
florida statues of corporal pusha do not
require schools to get parental consent
before they paddle students
with a paddle though that was that was
so hard though yeah
it's not like teaching them lessons no
that make me mad
yeah that reminds me of like your
parents hitting you at home not like
your teacher doing it yeah yeah
school and you just grab that [ __ ] i
know we're fighting yeah
you never did that no i was doing this
oh [ __ ] man i'd be like what
did i be like you like in the movie and
then close up on my hand and your hands
are shaking
that's a tough video to see yeah okay
so uh there was an article written
saying that snl cast members
would not be forced what a bunch of
babies well it's misleading
because there was an article that was
released saying that snl cast members
who weren't thrilled about elon musk
being on the show didn't have to perform
with him
why because of his stance on kovitz why
would you have a sex
you [ __ ] idiots some people just
didn't like the idea that elon musk was
going to be the host however
the article was very misleading because
this has been a rule in place for snl
for
as long as people could remember where
they didn't force any cast members to do
a skit or an episode with the person if
they don't want to
but no one's actually going out of the
way and saying like oh i don't want to
be here because elon musk is here but
someone wrote it's not like
that controversial yeah i can understand
if it was like trump or some [ __ ] like
that or biden but
isn't trump supposed to go on or did he
already go on
he's been on before years ago years ago
years ago you want to take you want to
read from your book
um how fun is that
what do you want to just read book he's
like yeah yeah he goes
is this live it's his live show yeah you
want to read through the book
yeah you know we tried him on uh king of
sting he's like
he's probably traumatized by him is he
alive
and we're gonna light you up a little
bit
but yeah no cast member has said that
they
wanted to sit out of this episode
although there were some that said that
they weren't thrilled about elon musk
hosting i don't get why they care
yeah i think he's being great on there
also they could use the
controversy like this absolutely
how about what michael chase said go up
chin uh
right there ask for michael tray the
weekend update host 37
to jimmy fallon this week that he hopes
the billing will uphold the snl
tradition
of a host giving a couple million
dollars
that's hilarious
that's great okay so the u.s
is currently facing a chicken shortage
and it's one
of well there are a few reasons one
there has been a chicken sandwich craze
that has been going on as of like the
last
since i would say like the popeyes
chicken sandwich thing yeah yeah their
chicken sandwiches are popping right now
so there is that
in combination with the pandemic and
people getting laid off
a lot of people are being happy with
just kind of collecting unemployment
checks and would rather not work
jobs like this and so they're finding
that
they don't have enough workers to then
process the chicken
and so we're currently facing a chicken
shortage nation as long as chick-fil-a
is good i don't even [ __ ] about anything
hey that popeye's chicken sandwich is
great it's good
it's not as good chick-fil-a chick-fil-a
is good she plays the best
i think i think it's a good battle i
think they're tied for me
they're time for you yeah yeah i can't
decide i can't decide
i i literally can't christian have you
had a helen ray's yet oh that's
happening
oh you ain't had holland raised i don't
even know what that is oh yeah it's a
chicken sandwich
do you like do you like spicy uh not too
spicy
i've had like dave's hot chicken that's
it's a really spicy yeah yeah that's
really good yeah
yeah probably i say david is like a
close to
second to helen ray i'll tell you as far
as like but helen's raise is like
holidays isn't fast food like fast food
chick-fil-a's number one but if
it's like best chicken sandwich periods
howling race yeah all right
i'll give it a give it a try we should
have another day where we've been yes
yeah we should
it's been a while yeah it's been a
little too late eat the hot one
i got the medium one it's perfectly hot
oh the media wait oh you didn't
i did the hot and i almost died what the
howling wing the really spicy one that
you wanted to try
to do yeah that would be dope remember
we're all in uh
nashville yeah it's nashville we ate
like three spots in one day
yeah we ate the hottest princess uh
it came purple yeah it was like triple h
black purple
jesus triple like triple s it was the
highest you could go it's like triple
and it was hot but it wasn't like you
weren't dying it was it was prince
prince prince street prince street yeah
right
yeah chicken princess hot peppers yeah
that's right yeah it was princess hot
chicken
whatever happened to the thick eats
video or did you guys even have one
yeah no we shot that in nashville yeah
also you can't just drop one episode of
it
also we're trying to lose weight though
now yeah i don't know
it's a little different now at the time
we were like hey yeah we're really
rubbing the bellies and [ __ ] all the
time yeah
speaking of bellies this is will smith's
post i love will smith for this he goes
i'll be real with y'all
i'm in the worst shape of my life
that's the funniest catch i'll be real
y'all
look at his body
in super great shape every time i see
him and i didn't realize that until i
saw this photo
he's also a lot older than you realized
like ben
ben stiller's always in good shape even
though he doesn't have to be mid 50s man
50 well smith 53 54 yep 52 52
52 years old september 25th is he older
or younger than brian
well how is he 52 brian's 50 brian's
yeah i know that because brian and i are
20 years apart his birthday is
the 26th i don't know he's 54.
i'm 34. but will will smith he'll easily
get back
he's gonna post that and then because
now he's gonna want some like weight
loss
in shape journey oh it's good cause he's
thinking about like yeah
great content for him like that's gonna
be hit the path next he's just getting
shaped for the summer
i mean it's gonna take him like a month
too he's gonna look at what he likes he
got on he's some
such a real post i know that's the
realest post ever i'm in the worship
mind worship
straight up
um okay i didn't get a chance to read
this but i guess it's the anniversary of
the bin laden
yeah so was it how long was it was it is
it 20 is it 20 years
may 1st 2011. no it's 10. 10 cents we
killed it oh yeah 10 years
oh yeah because we killed them nine
years after yeah that's right 10 years
what's this on may 11 2011 most
americans had never heard of
atabata bad by that night the dusty yep
all right so this just yeah it's just
the anniversary of them taking out bin
laden what's crazy that they
the history challenge did a whole thing
like yesterday going into the whole like
operation it was [ __ ] dope and
they're talking about how like
you know for nine years until obama came
in so when bush was president
the cia and fbi everyone's trying to
figure out where
cia not fbi that's local but uh national
but the cia was trying to figure out
where bin laden's at yeah
they had nothing and they would try to
every like
every week they tried to give an update
and they had nothing when obama came in
he was like man
he put all the resources into it and
then they started uh
some guy that they found was like hey
something suspect about this place over
in uh
pakistan he's like that makes sense like
it's this home
has 18 foot walls like someone of high
profiles there
you should look into it and that's when
i started looking into it and so then
they would get together
like we need to find out what's going on
in there they could never get a
confirmation with
osama bin laden so they brought that to
president obama
and he's like it's worth a shot they put
together the team and obviously you guys
know the story from zero dark 30 went
in there it was [ __ ] bin laden but
they were saying that
they're talking the navy seals the navy
seals were like yeah we and i can't
imagine the nerves that they had were
they watching it live
no they at the time they didn't have uh
they they were watching them land
and stuff live but they didn't have
cameras on them they didn't watch them
like no they didn't
knock out the operators all they did is
they got in the uh they got the
the [ __ ] walkie talkie where the [ __ ]
they use and they said uh geronimo
geronimo meaning
it's him but they still have a dna so
they put the dna
on one chopper and his body on another
in case
one of them got shot down they could
still validate that that was him
wait say that last word again they did
what so the problem is is because in
pakistan like you can't just fly in
there and take somebody out
so nobody knew even americans didn't
know this mission was going on so they
took
two choppers with navy seals on it and
landed right one crashed
so they had two choppers then they had
two choppers behind them that came
45 minutes after that had fuel and other
navy seals
in case ship popped off they'd drop off
these navy seals who would get them out
of there
so what they were worried about is even
after they take out obama or i'm sorry
osama if they realize that was him
and they get in the air they still got
to worry about getting shot down from
the pakistan
military because they don't have
clearance to fly there and kill people
so they're worried about even after the
mission when they get in the air they
get shot down by f-16s
so they put the his actual blood on one
chopper
and then the body on another so in case
it went down they could still validate
one of them that was something that it
was him it's nuts man yeah
but you hear the navy seals talking
about like yeah they said it was osama
you know such a high profile like we
couldn't tell anybody
like i couldn't tell my family or
nothing in the navy seals like it was
such a
like high level mission like the one the
navy seals were like yeah we were making
sure we had our
life insurance was all lined up because
we didn't you know such
such danger and then one day you see he
was like i've been some [ __ ] man
but this is the first time i ever wrote
a note to my wife and kid being like
like i was gonna die and then he was
like you know you just make sure like
all your shit's working before you get
out and like the
nerves they must have had man he was
like and we knew like it was the biggest
like mission ever in the history of the
cia
like so much was on the right and on the
line and they were saying that this one
day bc
when they got in the house like at first
they took like they
bust open the doors right they get in
and they're doing their mission and some
dude just start firing the
ak-47 off the bat and so they take him
out and they come and his wife picked up
gun they took her out
right and so they're going upstairs and
the one that's how gangster the name
seals are
the one guy saw that that he thought
that he's recognized as
osama's son but he was hiding he was
firing he was hiding
so he just mentioned his name to see if
he'd poke his head out and so he
whispered his name and he poked his head
and shot him right in the face
like think about being through all that
[ __ ] pressure
and having the [ __ ] brain power to be
like oh that's him
and then he was like we didn't know what
the [ __ ] he was doing like you whispered
his name and the
the son was like what he's like took him
out
david goggins that's he's a navy seal
right he was on those missions but yeah
no he wasn't on those missions but like
he he went through that like training
like this it's like crazy crazy you went
through buds yeah
but now what's crazy is they're saying
because navy seals are like
you know navy seals aren't really
supposed to be talked about and their
missions
but that was such a high profile case
now there's like this divide in the navy
seals
like he's causing issues because now
they're famous like everyone just thinks
every navy seal was on that mission they
weren't there's like
there's like 12 of them but now they're
saying like now like
maybe there's a dividing navy seals
because they have a you know they don't
talk about it man they're not supposed
to talk about it and a lot of these navy
seals made book deals and movie deals
oh sure yeah and that's not what they
that's not what they stand for it's
crazy
that osama [ __ ] is [ __ ] that's
intense oh i got that one i gotta watch
it i gotta watch zero
stood up was like i gotta watch zero
dark thirty now oh you've never seen
zero dark day
who's in it denzel no you you but it's
just about the story
yeah it's just about the story no the
guy from office isn't it you think
you're thinking of uh
um that movie uh 13 hours oh benghazi
in it she's great chris pratt's in it he
he plays the navy seal galaxy
he plays one of the navy seals oh this
is before he like popped yeah he was
like in this oh god
he's barely in it he's at the very end
what do you know frank grillo was in it
oh [ __ ] i didn't know he said either
oh the guy from uh the mike coulter the
uh what was his
what was his uh marvel show little cage
luke cage yeah right scotty i've seen
that dude in person
massive is he big cute tall
like just boom yeah that movie's [ __ ]
great though
yeah zero dark thirty is amazing okay i
gotta watch it when did it come but do
you the way they tracked them is the way
they got to osama is by
his couriers they had these two guys who
were pakistanian
and uh they had dual citizenship but
they realized they
they were the guys like do it like he
didn't he wouldn't osama wouldn't do
anything he didn't want to be discovered
right nine years on the [ __ ]
hook like run chasing so they followed
these couriers and they realized they
kept parking
into this pakistan structure and they're
like they're doing something in there
man that's how they caught them through
their cell phones
and they were listening to their cell
phones and they didn't know they're
being listed and they were smart about
because they knew
obviously everyone was trying to [ __ ]
take out osama and they
the the guy got a call from a friend he
hasn't talked to him forever
and this one they knew they're on to
something because they're listening to
the conversation the friend goes man
what you been doing dog
like where you been man i'm talking
forever you just go [ __ ] m.i.a he's
like
i'm busy he's like busy doing watt
though and the guy didn't want to talk
about and the guy's like no seriously
what the [ __ ] you been doing man
obviously he's speaking in [ __ ]
pakistani or whatever
and uh or farsi where are they talking
and he goes uh i'm doing what i used to
do again
and that's when like oh we got him
it's nuts damn nuts
it's fascinating seeing american sniper
oh yeah
for you you haven't seen any of those
movies have you what about it
i don't know i thought that was just a
really great movie as well i just wanted
to see if
he's seen that movie's great yeah i'm
the worst person to ask he's like one of
the most
like most successful you know [ __ ]
snipers of all time yeah the way he went
out though
super said so chris kyle so he was like
one of the most
yeah i know the story yeah and then he
was he got done with
his you know touring and [ __ ] taking
out bad guys
came back to texas and was trying to
help people with ptsd and he was trying
to take this guy out to the gun range
they get to the gun range the guy turns
the gun on chris collins kills him his
own guy
he's one of his own killed did that guy
kill himself yeah
what him and his friend and then led the
cops that kind of
took chris kyle's truck and led the cops
on a chase
it's crazy
yeah i mean you say you're a navy seal
in a bar right now in san diego dude
dick suck like that they're popping
tingling navy seal dick suck
[Laughter]
it's like a building you got a ring even
i'd get my hand job
you're a navy seal dog but there was
that site where people like fake valor
like people were saying their names
stolen valor have you heard about this
no so you know because it's so hot to be
navy seal now guys
balls are like oh that bar's been like
oh i'm a navy seal but they're around
other real navy seals i'm like oh really
oh i think i've seen like what are you
with people oh yeah
oh dude oh yeah there's like youtube
videos
what all the [ __ ] they've been through
like you're a navy seal yeah
how can you tell someone is actually a
navy seal like if
it's tough they probably they probably
have things that
they only they know that they could just
probably ask
i don't know yeah i'm sure you're like a
girl at a bar and someone's like i'm a
navy that's why they're doing it yeah
like
well when i was in college our
quarterback joel klatt was
pretty famous he said all these records
stuff like this we were at a bar
and this girl coming she's like joe
klatt's over there i'm with joel klatt
and he's all
what yeah joel class just and he threw
like for 400 yards against csu he's like
mvp of the game
and we're all going out to celebrate
we're like all the football players are
in the corner
and this hot chicks like joe clatt's
over there guys you know he's gonna buy
a round of bears and
the real joe clatt's like who where's he
at she's like over there he goes up and
he's like
you're joel clatton the guy's like yeah
man you know my arm and he's like oh no
diamond
i'm joking oh [ __ ] what a poser
yeah man why do the navy seal yeah
that's yeah that's a pretty bold one
yeah especially around like if you're in
like you know pacific beach like san
diego area
military area yeah that's a ball the
navy seals have got
so much attention it's not good like it
[ __ ] up their job now yeah
like they're so famous damn it's crazy i
have to pee really bad
you do yeah let's take a break i'll pay
with you navy seals
oh [ __ ] are you going to help him hold
it
yeah man what else you got jen
all right so it happened again
in china what do you think they had a
party no
something to do with plane that's racist
what do you say
you said it happened again
oh he said someone ate a bet oh plane
disappeared
another dude threw coins into the plane
engine for good luck oh
yeah tony hinchcliffe oh man
wait what happened they throw change
like their change
into the engine coins yeah it's like a
superstitious thing that they'll do for
good luck and so years ago
years ago uh you want to read from your
book yeah we had a
tony hitchcock on and we brought up the
story up and he's like how the [ __ ]
he's like she's he's probably burned the
plane going oh
make a win
how did they get near the engine when
you walk up to the plane some people
walk up to the plane
in burbank when you walk up oh yeah yeah
you've done that a few times yeah yeah
it's just no i'm not changing it oh
usually the engine's not even going
yeah that's so weird yeah so he's held
for 10 days
and fined 17 600 17 grand
and that's fair that's fair that's a
pretty
penny but that's cool because what did
how how did they know
i'm sure witnesses people saw it oh
witnesses yeah yeah or he's just
throwing a ton of them
yeah he just keeps going like five
dollars worth of penalties
hell yeah you made a good year
that's what i was saying too do you guys
know who this is who it is
yeah she looks completely different now
oh i would i would have
never like attracted for a while i know
she lost a bunch of weight yeah she's
clean now too she's sober
she fell off she was pretty heavy she
got oh she's happy
she was a heavy goth girl back in the
day yeah that's her
yes sir what the short kings are looking
he's
you never know well i would have never
guessed that to be her what so what's
the story
nothing i just thought you guys would
never guess it no there's no way in hell
but she fell back off she was going
flying straight for a while yeah she
said she
thought she could drink like a regular
person yeah that made me think of
chappelle
actually because uh she was sober for a
while and recently she announced that
she relapsed because
she thought that she could be like
everyone else where she could drink kind
of recreationally
every now and then but then she ended up
relapsing for real
she if i had one drink this is how goth
girls look like now though like gawkers
back in the day used to
look very different goth girl goth girls
are like hot as [ __ ] now
everyone knows how to contour she didn't
do anything like
surgery to her face either i feel like
she might have sure because the shed
she had large larger jawline so i wonder
if there's shaving or something like
that but who cares whatever
yeah she looks beautiful yeah she looks
great have you seen the uh have you seen
this video yet of this guy's hands
i'll just play for your hands go so fast
they started moving backwards
oh yeah this yeah yeah i see this
no that's not real thank you that's not
no
there's no way but sportscenter actually
posted this and then if you go to the
guys instagram
someone said here comes dylan dannis
trying to fight this guy
you could tell us it's fake watch
that's obviously fake yeah so put the
king of edits
anyways did you see the video of the
little girl like uh the little girl in
russia she was doing stuff like that
about on
a bare tree and that wasn't edited for
her
age oh yeah yeah yeah i didn't see it um
she was using that that guy's clearly
added yeah she was this girl was using a
tree as a punching bag
hey hey espn do better though
that's the most exciting thing this one
yeah
that girl
why is the footage so crappy still
because it's russia oh that's also the
2017.
she's a little beast that's four years
ago what's she doing now though
jesus christ
russia's just different man
and there's just a grizzly bear chilling
in the side like i get that [ __ ] girl
you need water how about 2.7
000 dislikes
god jesus christ oh my god
she bleeding at all she'd have to be
she's like a fighter i don't know if
she's how she's doing she's fighting now
yeah i look looked at her instagram like
a while back i don't remember damn
imagine that being your middle school
bully oh
nightmare nightmare
okay um that officer that did that
funny joke with lebron you know he was
playing his car so he got suspended
and then once he got started to go what
nothing
so they made a gofundme account and now
it's over so
oh good for him as of this article it's
250 000 but let's look right now
very refresh sorry 389 thousand dollars
wow yeah that video is [ __ ] hilarious
damn brandon
brandon tatum 5500
good for him man yeah oh oh i was like
who's brandon tatum
i see what you're saying yeah i was like
what are you talking about
damn brandon tatum baldwin good for him
yep and i think that's pretty much you
get all that money yeah
yeah yeah i would go find me yeah they
they don't take a percentage do they
know that the academy won't because they
have nothing to do with it go for me has
to take
money because you know the processing
yeah i would imagine like yeah
if you're using that platform they gotta
get some kind of percentage from sort of
like two percent or something yeah
processing fees well that's it because
how much does only fans take cat
uh only fan six a lot they take twenty
jesus
insane but to be fair they're the only
platform who lets you monetize like that
so if it wasn't for their platform
rachel ostervich begs to differ because
everyone asked her do you know who
rachel
is yes dime piece fighting beautiful
fighting bare knuckle now
swiss fight paige but uh i thought she
had only fans but she just does it from
her own site
i think a lot of girls will do that a
lot of girls will
now do that or they have an option where
you will buy something from them and you
pay their cash app instead of only fans
of the cut
isn't 20 wait so wait what does this
girl do she has her own website and
basically
you go to her website and you can unlock
these yeah so it's basically like oh uh
go on my website in order to use it you
have to pay a subscription fee
and then all the money then goes to you
yeah it's like when ck would sell his
lucy kay i did direct the fans on his
site
she's fashionable she's [ __ ] gorgeous
like that doesn't do her justice in
those pictures
and don't post those rachel but uh i was
like
no she's she's the best woman i think to
ever fight as far as like
attractive wise it's her page
oh you should hear him you beg the
difference
oh absolutely if you just keep going
down a little more yeah go that one
i'll go the one with her on the beach
that one's great
that one there you go jim okay she's
[ __ ] gorgeous what were you saying
though
christian
goddamn yeah doing it
but yeah i think somebody uh in my dms
reached out to me about uh setting up a
website or an app
where i would just get all the funds
myself
yeah that's not a bad idea it's not a
bad idea we're trained with only fan
it's like i've had so many people it's
just hard to
have youtube does this youtube does that
once you start your own it's like you
can
but it's just not as good not in the
algorithm yeah just not
yeah the you know i'd rather have five
percent of a million
than ten percent of a hundred thousand
that i own you know yeah that makes
sense absolutely
yeah that's the biggest problem right
now is that you could do that and you
can retain
all of that money but then the
likelihood of people following you from
one platform to another it just doesn't
transfer over
well all right but rachel
is doing the hopefully someone's you
know who's this who's who's the page one
page you know i've seen paige vance
she's been on the show i feel like
you've probably seen her but you're not
like a servant they're both in bare
knuckle
i'd say rachel's rachel's such a baddie
but paige is
different baddie go that first picture
she's a spider
she's a fighter good fighter too
that's more your speech pal
[Laughter]
wow yeah that's yeah
she she has her own see like this if it
it only
it only gets better new content drop it
don't miss out yeah i'm not mad at that
she has only fans she has her own
website no it's her own
paige fanzant
such a baddie yeah
so that's cool good god i know
dude if you're a pretty girl there's so
many ways to make money there absolutely
is
good for them pretty dudes can make
money
pretty dudes not like pretty girls
you're a hot girl
dudes with pretty feet can make money
too pretty feet yeah
i saw a guy who commented under a recent
photo of mine
he's a guy with really nice feet who has
the only fans for his feet
and apparently he does pretty well i
paid as well that that'd be a big it's a
niche but definitely like a game
monetization the gay community oh yeah
who cares what community it is no girls
let me let me see who cares what
community it is
it's
would you let your girl suck you like
are you into her
feet at all either of you or no if that
was her thing and she was like dying to
suck my toes
but i guess grab on ticklish so you
might get
her birthday is coming up she's like
have to suck my toes and like get more
power to you
a big toe i'm like girl you get a
mouthful
it is a birthday coming up if that was
like her thing i don't know
what about you pal hell no don't touch
my feet
where i draw the line is like pegging
yeah i feel like you're not well what's
wrong with you yeah
yeah i'm not trying to get females don't
give [ __ ]
that's not my thing what's wrong with
you are you
super into it yeah pegging uh because
i broke up with my uh boyfriend i was
dating around there was one guy that i
was kind of seeing
who would always ask me to peg him but i
would never do i was just too
intimidated like i can't
really but he would always put a strap
on him yeah and i would [ __ ] him i gotta
deal with some issues man
oh oh you gay bro that's fine
that's and i don't know that's fine do
you think i was way too intimidated but
no
i mean what so like pegging is strictly
like
a a girl has to be doing it to a guy yes
yes
because otherwise otherwise you're just
having gay sex
a big heart dick in your ass and that's
the gay sex
some girls are into pegging though yeah
some girls are into it
some girls day time it's like a power
thing big time it's a power oh
yeah i'm just i don't know i do a finger
but not like the
entire good for you if she was bad
enough
i was like this is the only way that i
can have my phone
she's like yeah like you had five
minutes
she was bad at five minutes bro i
couldn't do it she was bad oh if she was
like
smoke show like if paige and rachel were
like listen man the only way this can go
down if we can both pay you like god
dawg really
all right all right you got five minutes
all right man i'll bite my [ __ ] i'll
bite this pillow
zone off somewhere else and get through
this go to town ladies cause after this
five minutes oh god
and daddy's up yeah then daddy's up
yeah it's strange huh yeah how did you
gave me this
hey that's the thing everyone has their
people have their [ __ ]
sure there's actually i'm sure there's a
dating app like pegs rs or some [ __ ]
it's just boys yeah there probably is
man
like it's out there yeah people are into
that [ __ ] you know
i don't know how that works how did we
get there oh because we're talking about
sucking toes
guys and pegasus girl you playing with
fire
because i don't know how this works i'm
not a porno star i'm about to [ __ ] all
over your cheeks
if you think about it
you think about it like i don't know if
he takes one stroke and all of a sudden
if you i mean if you want it
there won't be any pegging going on this
thursday friday saturday
and uh kentucky just opened up capacity
so now there's tickets available
saturday was sold out now it's wide open
so now tickets are available for
thursday friday and
saturday one show thursday two shows
friday two show saturday
lexington kentucky then houston texas
houston improv may 20th to the 22nd it
will be me
chappelle and [ __ ] our boy lucas
lucas david luke gets his name every
time every time he does it because
david lucas doesn't see that i want to
change his name yeah you want to change
his name his name
is like look at his name should be craig
or something
he'll be here wednesday as a guest as
well he's just oh yeah we're excited for
him uh houston texas
with uh david lucas chappelle and myself
it's me a great [ __ ]
show man oh good that's houston texas
and oklahoma city bricks
bricktown comedy club june 10th through
the 12th get your tickets but i will see
you
this freaking thursday friday saturday
kentucky you on the clock let's run it
f-a-t-k-z.com chappelle will be really
helium philly this week man thursday
friday saturday
i'm excited oh hey and if you're a
videographer dm me
you need somebody in philly yeah yeah
definitely do that could you send me
your guy in kentucky
who didn't you send me a guy lexington
that's not my guy
oh he just messaged me oh it's like oh
yeah i didn't see it yeah yeah
but yeah if there's one out in philly
that'd be dope you didn't feel like uh
text me
side of my dna uh text me after you
connect with my boys at uh suplex
oh yeah i got you here yeah see if they
have any shoes for me too yeah see if
they have a shoe stretcher too
tell them these strap scouts don't fit
and you want everything yeah just see
what they say
but you're in philly this weekend man
doing your own [ __ ] and then may 13th
through the 15th i'll be in
uh raleigh north carolina at goodnight's
comedy club tickets at chapelle lacy.com
let's go let's go
i mean i'll miss you but nothing makes
me happier than when you headline your
own [ __ ] man
it's nice it's nice man it's nice and
people are
buying tickets to come see me you know i
ain't no i ain't no
brendan shop still out yeah you know i'm
getting there you know what i'm saying
there man i'll get there go see him
philly and then uh kentucky see you this
week
all right we out